today I'm going to play the hourly super
Blitz
and if this goes on YouTube
I'm going to time stamp every single
game in the video description
and I'm planning to play an aggressive
opening in every single game
so hopefully we'll have a nice mix of
gambits and just uh some entertaining
chess hopefully some instructive chess
too
but I'm gonna play in a more attacking
style than usual
the cow opening will wait
I did promise Anna cramling I'll play
the cow opening
uh every game in the upcoming title
Tuesday
okay berserking let me lower the volume
a little bit
and I'll start with E4
and we'll start with the Smith Mora D4
um if the opponent declines the Smith
Mora
I'll play D5 just grabbing space
there's already some traps like if takes
takes I'm threatening Queenie 2 and D6
in some cases
so
yeah this is already like very pleasant
for a while clamp down preventing B5
it does resemble like a benoni structure
usually the benoni is defined by black
Pawn on on C5 white Pawn on D5
um
if I want to be aggressive
I gotta play more quickly too I'll play
this move
and still developing
and now
yeah let's take and I'm gonna play D6
and this opens the D5 Square for the
Knight also opens up the diagonal for
the bishop
feels very close to
like winning something
Dole my Pawn oh no
I forgot I blocked the defense
dough my Pawn again I keep hanging my
Pawn
in all seriousness I think box Queen is
about to get trapped
if Queen takes a pawn there is Bishop F7
to win the queen
and in this line
wait am I trapping the queen here here
or here
might not be driving the queen
but we're gonna have some fun
I'll Navy be gameting
what two Pawns
only safe Square
and black house to find this move
I think we're pretty much guaranteed to
get the position after Queen takes A5
and do I have any discoveries
Queen B5
preventing castling
all right let's cement the bishop
in Knight T2
that's why I am down two pawns here
but look at my Godly Bishop
you don't see the structure every day
with a bishop on D5 and the pawn on D6
it's so hard for black to attack the
pawn because
uh
yeah the night is very far away from
attacking it
it's all Castle I'll probably go for The
Rook lift
I gotta still be aggressive
or the night lift
okay let's take and then Rook A3
and now the plan is to swing everything
over
and most of black pieces are not
defending the king
uh yeah let's hit F7
okay that was a fun game
stacked a couple Pawns
opponent didn't fall for the
for taking the poison Pawn but yeah once
I got the pawn to D6 life was pretty
good
now welcome to more people
if you're just joining I'm playing the
hourly super Blitz
um I'm not gonna berserk this game
maybe later in the tournament if I'm
like high up than all start berserking
and try and finish in first
but I do like having time
okay so this is a Stafford Gambit
declined uh I have this move
yeah let's be aggressive
if I have an aggressive option I'll I'll
play it so hitting the queen now C2 is
defended but one idea is to play maybe
this move
does it work though Knight D5
maybe F5 first
I want to remove the Knight
okay so I am gavining this Pawn
oh
wow okay I have two pawns on F4 and D F4
and E4
a knight's attack
oh fancy move
I'll admit I kind of miss that
but I think it's okay I'll play this
move
I'm gonna be losing the Rook most likely
but if white takes a rook
I can take and then threaten Knight
takes C2
so white might take the pawn here
but then I can develop
ooh
so I take the
yeah let's take on C2 first
wait this is It's a confusing position
I could also Play No Bishop D6 doesn't
work
I think I will take on C2 and then play
this
I'm giving white the option what to take
I might be down a rook at some point if
white does choose to take but I should
have compensation
yeah what a crazy position
there's a funny line Queen takes E4
Knight E3 and then Bishop here to win
the queen
so I'll play King F7
I mean we both have Knights all up in
each other's cribs
but I'm threatening to take the Rook
and now I win the queen
yeah this tactic is uh
maybe easy to miss given all the chaos
going on
thank you struggling Goose gifting to
harshit hehe
okay let's play this
this is a fork but it just loses a night
and now I have ideas of this and
almost trapping the night not quite
though
almost trapping the bishop but the
bishop can retreat
but things are looking pretty good here
let's get the Rook into play
and if takes takes this is mate next
move
because Bishop D3 is the only legal move
okay
so getting some
feel good quick wins
not asking for the hag face opening
I feel like that's not the most
aggressive thing I can play
not sure if it's gonna fit the street
the the theme of the Stream
and against D4
let's go for maybe a Budapest
yeah let's go for a Budapest
I will try and play a different opening
every game
um so this is a common line that
sometimes light will play against the
Budapest
and with this I wish I could go for this
and this specifications
oh thank you Malcolm
I think I can play this most aggressive
moves hit the pawn
and now yeah now Knight A6 so the idea
is to keep applying pressure to
white seemingly strong Center
and I'm hitting the bishop and the pawn
is capturable I think because Knight's
pinned
and this might lead to more tactics
because The Bishop's not defended
so I might be
I might be able to play this
now maybe I should just trade
to do
there there 13 whole months of dragons
hmm
it's I play Sicilian Dragon welcome back
okay let's keep the bishop
a nice piece to have
and now if I play this do I have to
worry about the Greek gifts
also I have to worry about my time
berserk this game I guess I did
I have an idea this and then this or
this
actually what's my idea
okay don't meet me
maybe this
so I do defend
I play much quicker
um
I really wanted to maneuver the knights
but
we might be trading at least I'll get a
rook to E8 hopefully
or not
let's take yeah rookie it's coming
there's a funny idea Rook here and then
here
oh this move
not sure if it works but if takes I win
The Rook
interfering with the relationship
between the Rooks
and now I take
still being aggressive
I want to play this move next
in 15 seconds
preventing rookie one
my Pawn should be on light squares to
restrict the lights with Bishop
okay
let's start pre-moving
foreign
a little bit slow
ah
let's go
okay
1.6 seconds to spare oh man
Eric welcome back
so much for the last 1005. hey happy 51
months
okay
uh what a thrilling game
all right so we have G6 one of the most
aggressive ways to play against G6 is
this um really H Pawn push
when it's going for a hippo
I'm kind of gameting the e-pawn but
not getting that
Queen F3
okay I'm still trying to like mentally
cool down from the last game
I like this position
some nice piece Harmony
ready to
maybe maybe pounce with this move
and now
yeah let's go back because the e-pawn's
hanging
another four or F4 coming
F4 chasing away the knight from
defending the pawn
yeah trying to manage my time
a bit better compared to last game
hmm let's play this
attacking the pawn again
if the pawn moves I play Bishop F7
I think he'll still go for Bishop F7
and then Knight D5
almost trapping the Queen the queen has
to move here
maybe go for D4
it's hard to be more aggressive than
this do I sack the piece
there there
[Music]
let's move back
maybe D4
[Music]
yeah I want to open the center
in such a beautiful position
the king does find some safety
I guess I have to be patient
it feels like full domination though
it's just gonna be hard to Checkmate the
king quickly
so I have to gradually build up now I
have a hole to work with
this E6 Square
a gaping hole
this bishop would be dangerous if there
wasn't a pawn here
now it looks like I'm guaranteed to get
a 96 eventually
uh yeah let's go for this
oops
that's other Bishop becoming dangerous
my Rook is attacked
okay that was a small slip this is not
gonna be easy
and the bishop is hanging
I mean it still feels good
just have to be a bit more focused
King moves here I have Knight C7 now I'm
turning Bishop E6
can probably pre-move this
yeah the other Rook will come in
oops
I forgot that I could do that
it's still looking good I have a lot of
minor pieces
uh let's play this
oh no
I hung I hung my thing but black didn't
take it
okay that's helpful
not the cleanest conversion here but
getting the job done
G7 coming
where's my mate
Bishop D2 checkmates
okay another close call
uh yeah I got a little bit too
comfortable with the full domination in
the middle game
that was a fun game though
okay so 15 tournament points
leader has 36 berserk winning most of
the games
almost every game
24 minutes left
okay berserk
so I play the Stafford declined
hoping for a Stafford accepted
um so now we have a symmetrical Italian
which can be hard to be aggressive
against but the one aggressive idea is
H6 G5 push
which I'm going for
and this pin is already
kind of annoying for lights Knight T4
coming
that with Rook G8 maybe I can take first
and then
yeah I got the queen involved got the
Rook involved eventually take
yeah this this might already be like
very bad for white
but I don't want to speak too soon
take First Take
yeah so I'm threatening made in three
with check check and then Rook G8 mates
which yeah light does not stop
okay so that worked out nicely
yeah when you think of symmetrical
Italian especially playing the black
side you think that it's going to be uh
a long struggle to win but
as we just saw
my G Pawn Save the Day
uh no berserking this game let's play uh
D4 let's play an aggressive line within
D4
I'll play Knight C3 and we'll have
jobava London
E4
and now
uh what's the way to play here
let's take
maybe D5 could have been more aggressive
but there's still ideas of eventually
playing Knight B5 to C7 in it even if we
do trade Queens
so Bishop D7
Bishop D7 Knight B5
can that work there there
because I'm calculating
um never mind
maybe C3 now
the light side down to defending the
squares and I can't take the pawn
if E6 I play B4
if that I take a free Knight
okay winning in eight moves can't
complain
yeah a lot of these games have actually
been pretty quick
at least getting winning positions
pretty quickly
that's berserk again
so if E4 maybe I'll mix things up
could play a scandi
play scandi with Knight F6
can be a nice Blitz opening
opponent deep in thought
yeah it's already very complicated
so double edged Arrow
hmm
I think I'll play if
[Music]
what to do here maybe bishop G4
it's a more aggressive option so pinning
the Knight
because white wanted to play Knight C3
okay if G4 I win The Rook
build up pressure threatening to take
and probably take
wow both Queens are hanging
take take
I think I'll play Queen E4
White's Queen is still hanging
if Bishop E2 I think I can take
What's Happening Here
there's also Queens like castling
which looks really nice
yeah this is like a dream come true
scandi
like very much developed E5 happens the
d-pawn and the Knight are pinned the
white Knight's pinned in two directions
F3 might have to be played
can I sack Bishop F3
actually F3 I can probably play this
move
G3 and then come back
Bishop E3
so I think the goal is to take keep
taking on D4 until the pawn takes back
and then Bishop B4 should be
pretty lethal
or I can take the queen
okay
nice quick win with a scandi this is
going very well so far
in third place still 10 points out at
first
but
staying clean avoiding losses
oh I see a mention of the Tennyson
which my opponent did not play last game
maybe I'll play 903 I'll go for a
Tennessee if D5
if that how do I be aggressive
Knight C3
and E4 okay
so now we have a
a periods Bishop G5 maybe I'll play this
line with
so with H6 included
I'll go for office like hassling
and maybe this idea maybe this idea like
E5 eventually
if black plays E5 it loses a pawn
so yeah G4 looks nice because I want to
play G5 and open up some lines
wow
let's play this
blocking the diagonal opening up this
diagonal
and now if B4 my knight can centralize
hmm
let me just put all the things on the
king side
like I'm okay with the trade because
black used a lot of time to
get rid of that Bishop
and the plan now is each for H5
we gotta start with gaining space in the
center
and Bach's still fighting for sure
before maybe coming if B4 maybe I just
ignore it
play this move
because I have three attackers against
G6
now the H file opens
and good things should happen for me
I'm just sacking everything this better
be mate
and if if takes B2 I play King B1
the king is actually very safe using the
black pawn as a shield
and now if takes isak the Rook
and I think that's Force mates
and I'm threatening made in one with uh
the Double checkmate
black has no time to take on D5
32 seconds should be plenty of time
even if I had like two seconds
maybe still winnable
this is meat in a couple
yeah actually I just needed one second
there okay so in second place
still okay 15 minutes left
um I'll berserk back okay we'll have a
90 second game I'll play Knight C6
this is called the black Mustang
and I'll actually go for a reverse Grand
Prix
it's a nice solid aggressive opening
like solid aggressive maybe sounds like
an oxymoron but there's a lot of solid
openings that are also
um also leads to like middle game
attacks
so my attacking ideas usually involve
this
Knight Knight D5 was kind of annoying
I'll play this
which looks weird but just defend the
pawn
and if takes I'm happy to lift The Rook
meanwhile
I mean
yeah let's just go all out Connect Four
I might be regretting this
it's super interesting though okay my
Bishop should be back here
no reason for it to be on B8
huh
might be in trouble here
take take
try this
I think we have to trade Queens
oh this is not a good position
[Music]
this is definitely the worst position
I've had so far this tournament
yeah
foreign
[Music]
I'm going to need a miracle here
oh no
I'm just getting mated
any stalemate tricks
no
I'm getting upon me oh
wait It's Not Over
hope and pray
okay
oh that backfired
okay still within range of winning the
tournament though
I'm five points behind
first place or second place is on my
tail
the second place is a person who I just
lost to so that was kind of the
important match of
what to do
I wonder if I'll play this person or no
they're playing currently
okay less than 12 minutes left
the aggressive play won't stop
you know I think I've lost rating points
as tournaments after that last game uh
let's go back to E4
and oh let's play Tennyson
okay
see how prepared my opponent is
iPhone's playing the most common line
which
does blunder the queen
I'll take a pawn
check
no mercy here
no mercy
okay like Queen went on a rampage
that's how it's a detil it from the
previous game
yeah I think that trap is also called
the intercontinental ballistic missile
maybe a nice analogy for my queen there
okay Noob is working
I think this is the highest rated
opponent I've played so far
I'll still try and play quickly and
aggressively
um let's play Sicilian
okay this is the most aggressive line I
know against the close Sicilian
I'll go for a quick D5
uh opponents going for this one
um yeah this is actually a very tricky
line from the white side
I do have to be careful here
I know taking the piece was not supposed
to be good
um
that's probably a good move
maybe this move
uh oh
am I in trouble
Queen H5 G6 takes takes takes
this line Looks fascinating
so first of all I have this move
but
I'm really curious about this move
because I'm gonna lose a rook and then I
take here
and then my Knight's hanging but White's
Bishop is hanging
I don't know what's going on here
but I can't complain I mean the the
style of this position definitely fits
what I was going for
um can I sack more
I think I should save the Knight
so I'm down what I have nine Pawn for a
rook
I think I want a castle and just
complete development
if White Castles I can throw in the
check unleash the queen
yeah Knights defends the bishop
if white trades off the bishop then I
have Queen E3 check ideas
Queen E5 might be played
then can I take on C2
can I play this now
let's start with this
get the file
hmm
B3
maybe this
going for A2 if King B1 Bishop D5
oh but then
B3
I think I'll still go for this because
B3 we can C3 now I just want to get the
Knight to B5
this maneuver is a idea
so I'm I'm still down the exchange
but my knight could potentially be
better than a rook
and yeah the intention is very clear
so white might end up sacking back
okay it's getting tactical take take
take
you can avoid the train
hmm
go for this
if I take let's just go for this
yeah
to take
yeah White's gonna sack pack
although then I
does it work
because the bishop hangs
yeah I think White had to take her first
because the Queen's tied down to
defending the bishop
and now White's realizing it
but it's still tricky
take take
not sure what's going on here
hmm
I can't do that
do this
trying to play it safe
okay
oh I had to hold on there oh it's close
so this person so the leader um is no
longer leading
it's a three-way tie for first
but this person's on the streak
and they're currently in a game
and they've berserked
okay
so I have to uh I probably have to get
into more games
after berserk regardless
okay E4 I have to play the most
aggressive I played so far
which means another Smith Morena
but this time it's Smith more accepted
um what's the line here Bishop F4
95 okay being super super aggressive
opponent doesn't take it
um let's go for this
honestly it didn't calculate this line
but it looks fun
uh because how does black defend the
night Knights pin to The Rook by my
battery King I fade is maybe the only
move
King f8 Knight G5
and Knight is still pinned
yeah if we trade everything King f8 Rook
E1 in the end Rook ae1
interesting
threatening meat still all box pieces
are undeveloped except this thing
uh let's play this and then
how to break through this move
foreign
has 40
.
what's my quickest way to mate
this idea let's go back
and this
I probably go for this
light's completely stuck
watch out for weird tactics with a pawn
um
play this first
loofed
oops
yeah this backfired
oh no
I'm actually in trouble here
take take that's a great move
yeah this game won't count for the
tournament
unfortunately
or fortunately
out here
take the thing oh that's
okay good game
that was still a fun tournament
I finished outside the top three
finishing fourth
last game actually didn't count for the
tournaments what to do
I hope people still enjoyed it
I think this will still go on YouTube